vous montre un pc complètement dingue un
pc que je vous ai montré lorsque j'étais
aux crs en tout début d'année ça y est
ils arrivent il est commercialisé dans
le monde entier en europe en france est
vraiment dans le monde entier c'est un
nouveau essais de asus tout le premier
pc d'asus qui vient se plier c'est celui
alors là il est plié le nom exact il est
là c'est le asus et le zenbook 17 foid
oled asus les la marque bourbon sont les
pc sont les ordis 17 c'est la diagonale
17 pouces voir un tout petit peu plus
folle explique oleg d'une dalle oled
comme ça vous êtes toutes les
informations c'est une machine qui est
super intéressante parce qu'à plein de
façons différentes de venir l'utiliser
donc aujourd'hui on voit qu'un
destinateur on va regarder s'il
intéressant ce qui est fait pour vous et
surtout le tarif appartient de
3999 c'est pas pour tout le monde mais
c'est une belle innovation a mis la
gomme
tout se passe ici regardez c'est ça ça
c'est votre pc alors c'est un bouquin on
pense que c'est un bouquin un bouquin
avec un petit trépied qu'on peut venir
qu'à aller comme ça mais en actes et
c'est un pc alors le pc vous le prenez
vous l'ouvrez je vous ai laissé le
clavier à l'intérieur mais normalement
le clavier il est pas avec eux l'avoir
bien évidemment et ça c'est votre pc ça
c'est quand même assez énorme parce que
vous regardez vous le prenez vous le
mettez comme ça je prends hop asus je me
connecte vous avez donc ce pc avec cette
webcam ici avec de la faim rouge une
charnière là il vient se plier dans un
sens dans l'autre regardez il vient là
comme ça vous le plier le faire mais
faites gaffe de ne pas les faire tomber
vous pouvez le mettre comme vous
souhaitez et en fait ce truc là est
vachement vachement intéressant alors il
sera parfait pour tout le monde parce
qu'aujourd'hui ça coûte très très cher
et donc le même les rats dans ce sens là
si on le veut il sera très clairement
partie pour tout le monde parce que
c'est l'innovation où l'innovation
commence toujours avec un tarif très
élevé mais c'est une belle innovation et
ça monte là où on va aller au niveau des
pc l'heure pas forcément sur tous les pc
mais ça montre si tous les usages de ces
écrans qui se plie alors c'est pas la
première fois que je montre un pc avec
un écran qui se plie mais c'est la
première fois qu'on a la version d'asus
la copie d'asus avec des specs de dingue
avant de vous parler des spectres montre
vraiment le côté visage donc vous l'avez
différentes manières on va déjà pouvoir
mettre comme un pc un petit peu
classique c'est à dire que vous venez de
plier la regarder ça vous fait une
espèce de grand pc mais vous prenez
votre clavier vous posez votre clavier
lui dès lors que clavier est positionné
à garder il vient se remettre en place
je le prends je le mets comme ça il
revient et là j'ai un petit os windows
que je peux venir utiliser c'est un
windows donc là j'ai mon clavier hop là
le trackpad je vais l'utiliser c'est
très facile ça c'est la première chose
devenir également faire la même chose
mais avec un clavier
actuel je veux venir taper un truc ici
hop là j'ai un petit clavier virtuel je
disparais et ça me fait un grand écran
ça c'est le deuxième usage comme ça
l'autre usages et bien c'est je le
prends je louvre alors là juste en bas
ici je viens levé le très piégeux le
poste comme ça là bon alors c'est un peu
le max et là je viens prendre se pose
mon clavier devant et là je viens
également naviguer l'utiliser donc je
peux dire déplacer mon clavier le mettre
sur les genoux je suis un peu la coulée
je peux venir bosser avec ce très grand
écran et là j'ai une diagonale
complètement dingue là je sors du 17,3
pouces très costaud j'ai aussi le tablet
mode c'est à dire que je le prends et
j'utilise comme ça ça me fait une petite
tablette ça vient a pivoté c'est un peu
le mot tablette donc je le prends sur
mes genoux comme ça voyez je viens de
signer j'ai griffonné je fais tout avec
mes doigts c'est très pratique je peux
également venir lire si je veux me
prendre un petit bouc jeu le pli
légèrement comme ça je peux la voir d'un
côté loge par offres différentes
applications aussi je souhaite à la main
c'est aussi pas mal et puis le dernier
c'est l'extended mode c'est à dire qu'il
est comme ça hop là il est plié je mets
mon petit clavier ou je veux à côté et
là je peux venir utiliser mon pc cette
manière là également avec une
application en haut une application en
bas lors d'un point de vue logiciel seas
intelligent parce que en fait garder il
vous met en bas un petit mode pour vous
montrer ça là pour venir choisir la
disposition de vos pages alors le truc
est très marrant je vais vous ouvrir par
exemple regardez j'ai fait un petit
world et j'ai fait un excellent la gelée
également ici le raccourci juste là
j'appuie dessus j'appuie juste là ça me
propose ça et là tiens j'en veux une en
rouge en voit qu'une en bas et paf ça
avant mais une rosamond mais une en bas
donc là je peux bosser en eau sur un
tableur faudrait faire un peu de
traitements textant bas peut également
se mettre sur un navigateur et il
travaille et en os sur un tableur faire
des copier-coller déplacer bref c'est un
pc donc c'est très facile au toc lie
très malin alors j'essaie de dispo là
mais je peux cliquer là voyez je suis
dispo 1-2-3 donc là on va se dire par
exemple quoi on explorateur de fichiers
j'appuie sur leurs 2 3 et ça vient tous
de mettre en place alors là j'ai
l'explorateur de fichiers qui est en
haut tu as forcément ce que je veux mais
après il ya réorganiser les choses comme
je le veux très facilement et je trouve
ça vraiment extrêmement mal à nous
envoyer c'est très très cool à chacun de
trouver ces usages alors sur un pc qui
coûtent quasiment 4000 euros très
clairement on n'est plus pour des
personnes déjà qu'ils aiment
l'innovation des early adopters heures
on est plus sur des gens qui ont les
moyens très clairement on est surtout
sur du chef d'entreprise qui veut
vraiment la nouveauté au tec et qui veut
vraiment se faire plaisir parce que
c'est pas aujourd'hui un pc que venir le
commun des mortels alors ça c'est le
premier truc deuxième séquence que vous
le tenez à la main comme ça on est sur
un pc qui fait 1 kg 5 avec le clavier
fait 300 grammes on est sûr qu'il a eue
dans bon ça c'est pas mal mais tenir à
la main c'est vrai que c'est un petit
peu lourd donc le mode liseuses comme ça
où on en vient bouquiner je suis pas
convaincu parce que très honnêtement ça
pèse un peu l'histoire ça je suis très
convaincu par contre lorsque vous
l'ouvrez que vous venez de poser et que
vous posez le clavier dessus sachez
extrêmement convaincu parce que je
trouve ça vraiment malin et très très
pratique lorsque vous voulez aussi
l'utiliser en très grand écran et que
vous le prenez comme ça là ça je suis
convaincu à 300% vous avez une dalle qui
est monstrueuse donc ça je suis
extrêmement convaincu et j'y crois avec
votre clavier devant voyez savoir vous
voyez t'es pas comme ça ça fait un truc
tellement grand c'est tellement
appréciable que ça j'y crois à 300% un
truc qui est intéressant c'est que vous
avez un clavier qui quand même pas trop
mal fichu alors il est tout plat il
étouffe un vous avez un petit bouton
pour venir l'allumer et l'éteindre la la
prévenir le charger juste ici sinon il
n'y a pas grand chose c'est très très
standard vous le prenez vous le posez
alors on a une course de touché quand
même suffisamment longue et qui est pas
mal on a un bon confort les touches sont
assez grande et pas trop petit donc on a
vraiment tout le confort qu'on attend
aujourd'hui d'un petit clavier le seul
truc c'est que comme il n'est pas
légèrement voyez inclinée est ce qu'on
va pas se fatiguer un peu le poignet au
gouvernement bon faudrait enfin pendant
des heures et des heures et des heures
pour vous le dire le trackpad est pas
mal aussi il fait le taff bon c'est un
accessoire que je trouve quand même pas
mal plutôt bien fichu c'est vrai qu'on
pourrait se dire attendre un tout qui a
un peu faim sur un pc à quatre mille
balles mais si dans la vienne parce
qu'en fait ce que vous faites c'est que
vous le prenez vous leur posez vous
refermez et on the go vous êtes parti
d'autant plus que la juste nous a fait
une petite pochette avec vous venez le
glisser dedans pour le côté premium on
est sur une machine extrêmement premium
dont hbo affaires hyper gaffe moi j'aime
bien alors j'avais avait déjà montré les
finitions se produit lorsqu'on l'avait
vu à las vegas ensemble je sois très
très cool vous avez en plus ici un petit
système de tir post petit cale pied qui
va vous permettre de le poser lorsque
vous le mettez droit comme ça avaié à
plat ça lui même tire un petit angle
alors bon il faut mettre le follower
derrière ce en quoi ça va se casser la
gueule mais je trouve que c'est pas mal
quoi vous voyez ça vient de le caler
comme ça sur les petits pieds avec le
triplea d'arrière bon hockey plutôt bien
fichu alors on va parler un peu plus
tech maintenant au delà des usages moi
je veux qu'on parle un peu de cette
dalle parce qu'on est quand même sur une
dalle ici c'est vu une dalle qui se
plissent et d'ual c'est flexible oled ça
peut être que du oled aujourd'hui là
dessus avec une charnière qui a quand
même été testés pour être pliée plus de
30 mille fois on est loin des pc on est
loin des smartphones parce que sur un
smartphone je vois notamment samsung
galaxy z flip 4 vous êtes folle de 4 peu
importe les annonces 200000 pliure
ouverture/fermeture on va ouvrir bien
plus souvent un smartphone qu'on ouvrira
en fait c'est le tube je trouve assez
robuste c'est toujours compliqué de se
projeter dans le temps et de se dire
qu'est ce que ça va donner mais comme il
est là je trouve pas mal sous le doigt
on sent un léger truc mais vraiment pas
grand chose donc comme on est sur le
foot un peu plus large au niveau de la
pliure que ce qu'on aurait sur un
smartphone on va - voyez payer venir
pincer l'écran donc ça permet d'avoir un
truc qui va être un peu moins démarquer
ici un peu plus confortable quand il est
complètement ouvert comme ça vous avez
une dalle de 17,3 pouces et de l'oled ça
c'est un format 4/3 lorsque vous venez
le fermer c'est du 12 points 5 et là
vous êtes sûre du 3 demi 1/2 ans au 3,2
me en bas là vous êtes sur du full hd en
au full hd en bas lorsque vous l'ouvrez
complètement vous êtes sûre du 2,5 cas
c'est dû à 2560 par 1920 ici à 60 hertz
60 images par seconde donc on va pas
demander beaucoup d' images par seconde
et c'est pas un pc qui va être fait pour
venir jouer à des jeux pour faire un peu
diminué truc très rapide mais tout ce
qui va nécessiter de la performance de
la puissance bon ou pas des masses dans
son point de vue graphique ici on a
uniquement une intel il y 6 e donc on va
pas avoir grand chose et beaucoup de
performances graphiques derrière vous
avez un processeur qui est assez
puissant c'est la douzième gêne c'est un
i7 ou pour tout ce qui va être multi
applications pour couvrir quelques
petits programmes ça ira très bien un
peu de lightroom soit la retouche petit
look et ça ira tous la nécessité de la
ressource graphique derrière notamment
de la vidéo on va pas venir le faire ici
il est pas taillé pour il a musclé pour
un écran qui est certifié dolby vision
certifié weesa display hdr troubles ac
500 on a un temps de réponse à 0,2
millisecondes il est également certifié
par thaïlande pour lutter contre la
lumière bleue il est certifié pantone
100% dci p3 et il a un pic de luminosité
à 500 dit ça c'est vraiment le côté
dallas et un bel écran il est vraiment
bien fait je trouve extrêmement
confortable à venir utilisé pour
regarder des films des séries faire ce
que vous voulez alors attendez je vais
vous montrer maintenant on va aller sur
youtube le clavier très très grand
talent et virtuel c'est vachement
confort à venir faire on va se mettre
ici au plat on tape monsieur greu alors
je vous faire écouter un truc vous allez
voir
ça c'est moi le volume est ici je trouve
ça a tendance à saturer lorsque vous
montez le son trop fort vous avez quatre
haut parleurs un un peu de tous les
côtés on a quatre micros également pour
venir enfin la conf call et compagnie
quand je le pousse à flot surtout là
dessus et j'avais 3 ans là ça va leur
mettre la musique vous allez voir
c'est hyper médium
c'est pas beau ça c'est sûr un peu et
c'est pas ouf donc on va pas bien le
pousser à fond de toute façon c'est une
certitude
mais autant vous avez un volume sonore
autant je trouve que le rendu est pas
super super dingue et ça vient pas ici
ne surprend pour voir qu'on est certifié
harman kardon et dolby atmos voilà pour
revenir sur la performance et si vous
avez à 16h drame c'est là le pddaa 4x
vous avez un terrible de stockage en ssd
et puis surtout si on a une
certification et vos ouailles côté
batterie alors on pourrait dire on a un
truc très fin et à des affidés de bordel
quand même c'est vachement fin et bien
en fait vous avez une batterie de 75
watts heure à l'intérieur avec de la
recharge 65 watts avec son petit bloc
qui hélas a lancé écrit comme le port
salut je vois plus aux 65 watts voyez
une fois la petite lumière 65 watts truc
est aussi intéressant c'est que on est
sur du windows on va alors windows en
bon ok on connaît aujourd'hui mais comme
on est chez rhésus gardez vous venez là
vous avez tout plein de petites
applications on va aller par exemple sur
bail asus ou là vous avez plein de
petits réglages qui sont vachement cool
ou là vous avez beaucoup de choses au
niveau de la personnalisation au niveau
de la batterie faire attention à ce que
vous venez de recharger le mode de
ventilation performance standards
silencieux les micros avec la réduction
de bruit oui non quoi comment haut
parleurs avec la suppression de bruit
asus oled caire gradation oled sans
scintillement aussi au niveau de l'écran
alors là je voulais laisser en normal
peut le mettre en vie il faut mettre en
manuel au niveau de la protection des
yeux c'est très jeune c'est dégueulasse
a donc très honnêtement vous laisser en
normal et ça ira très bien il ya pas mal
de petites options qu'on peut venir
faire ici au niveau de la webcam aussi
activer désactiver optimisation de
l'éclairage furaya plan suivi des yeux
suivi mouvements latéraux admettre ça on
va se mettre le suivi des yeux et on
vient ici on vient dans la caméra on
vient choisir sa petite caméra alors
vous positionner la voix l'a envoyée
regardez ça vient me sens très mes yeux
en fait comme si je regardais là et on
veut en fait c'est le fric et ses
histoires qu'on ait l'impression que je
regarde toujours devant moi il ya un
truc qui est quand même pas très naturel
mais bon c'est assez rigolo je vais
avoir le flou de l'arrière-plan
d'envoyer la sa flûte monde en
arrière-plan donc voyez j'ai quelques
petites options logicielles qui sont
assez marrante ici détecteurs du wifi
orange boues stockées fin voilà il ya
pas mal de petites choses qu'on peut
venir faire et qu'on peut venir optimisé
directement ici d'un point de vue
purement logicielle donc à juste ici
niveau software ils ont mis le paquet en
retrait un truc qui est très cool et on
peut venir personnaliser totalement
l'expérience au niveau de l'utilisation
de son pc avec c'est marrant stick la
10e bien alors ici on nous annonce 24
heures d'autonomie 24 heures de a à z en
vous n'avez pas l'utiliser pendant 24
heures et vous venez de recharge est
extrêmement rapidement ici donc ça c'est
bien autre chose qu'il faut savoir c'est
qu'en fait sur cette machine vous avez
deux ports thunderbolt cassé l'usbc vous
en avait un qui est situé juste là qui
est venu d'une prise jack compris dia
qui vous servira pour venir connecter un
casque mais également un petit un micro
facilement qu'est-ce que micro pour
venir converser ici une prise
thunderbolt 4 et vous en avez une autre
qui est situé juste ici en haut là parce
que vous êtes comme ça peut venir
brancher un moniteur externe branché sur
le côté ici mais le seul truc c'est
comme vous n'avez que deux et bien ce
que voulaient venir recharger vous
embaucher une ici une là et une là sinon
après il faut acheter un petit aide
extérieure pour pouvoir avoir d'autres
temps bon ça peut se faire également et
on comprendra très clairement qu'on va
pas nous mettre des quantités des
quantités de porc vu la taille de la
machine autre truc on a du wifi 6e et on
a une langue militaire c'est la mil std
810f donc voilà pour ce pc alors très
clairement moi ça me fait marrer parce
que ça très cool de voir l'innovation et
j'adore voir l'innovation ici sauf qu'il
très très belle innovation signée asus
faut-il mettre quatre mille euros dans
ce pc je pense qu'aujourd'hui la réponse
non mais ce qu'on voit et c'est très
clair l'innovation est toujours par le
haut du panier ça coûte très cher et
puis petit à petit il y en a de plus en
plus la concurrence fait rage les prix
baissent et on retrouve des techno comme
ça qui font super intéressante moins
cher alors pas tout de suite 1 500 by
très clairement mais peut-être qu'on
pourra rivaux entourent des 2000 euros
plus tard à l'avenir on sait pas en tout
cas moi je trouve ça marrant à l'idée
d'avoir envoyé ces espèces de grands
écrans pour la modularité pour du
déplacement j'ai ici mon petit truc
regarder je vais me déplacer je vais
ouvrir mon windows à distance donc je
peux le poser à distance france a il
peut mettre sur ma joue c'est très léger
tout s'écoule en fait pour bosser en
modularité en déplacement vous souhaiter
à vous baladez vous le prenez vous le
plier vous mettez les claviers dont et
vous reprenez la route donc ce truc là
est cool ce truc là est marrant ce truc
là montrent en tout cas un des
possibilités au niveau de l'univers du
pc c'est une des possibilités de la même
manière qu'on l'a au niveau du
smartphone avec les écrans qui ce pli
c'est chouette de voir cette technologie
d'écran flexible nous permet d'avoir des
produits comme ça qui sont un peu hors
du commun et très cool quoi ça pourrait
vous tentez vous est-ce que vous verriez
avoir un pc qui se plie comme ça signé
asus alors s'il vous intéresse il sera
dispo sur l'appstore et j'ai quelques
autres partenaires bien évidemment les
liens en bas dans la description mais
faut-il encore avoir envie et faut-il
encore pouvoir le faire de maître en
1999 euros dans cette machine là aussi
cool soit elle dit moi ce que vous en
pensez on va en commentaire - une fois
de plus très belle elle est aussi très
belle technologie très belle maîtrise de
l'écran de la part de la justice il ya
plein de choses que je optimiserait
l'audio et compagnie mais c'est une très
belle machine et en termes de confort de
visionnage de confort d'utilisation et
pour toutes les personnes qui veulent se
déplacer très facilement vous avez un
truc chouette pour autant j'aurais peur
de me faire tirer donc je le plan créé
un peu je présente dans un sac fait
quand même son petit pour 1 kg 5 comme
ce à quoi on se dirait comme ça un truc
que former facilement je le dis c'est
dans un petit sac comme ça et j'aime me
balader sa faim kg sac je mettrai plus
dans un sac à dos mais bon ça me plaît
bien il pose que vous en pensez en bons
commentaires nous on se retrouve très
vite pour continuer évidemment appareils
étaient cassés c'est plein de nouveaux
produits faisant grâce prenez soin de
vous et à très bientôt des bisous mis ko
[Musique]